now what happens as we go through these
messes they do require a more
understanding of what is going on so you
might find this method of doing it
through I'm a bit confused they are a
bit hard to understand but they are what
you understand them live in superior
methods to this they are even a bit
quicker and they will also serve you
very well we're we're doing more than
just this this is a bit of a product set
for economy there's not a good one this
is the 15 years you are drawing each
other you know before eight years you've
drawn it in a sense you're going to
unicode uncertain how the question says
sine theta equals proper half our
hardest thing to remember is we redeploy
in sine cos of hair we said you know
what together is writing retail forget
about that opposite of my pot needs
adjacent stop sign close and can just
refer to specifically sign code they
reflect something about the cold water
under the context of the incircle what
is the coordinate is confidence and what
is sine feed us you remember which one
is which yeah
yes considering the exporter and that
makes a bit up the y-coordinate welcome
spring around Pacific now one of the
easy sites do you remember that is X&Y
alphabetical conveniently cuz inside a
wholesome Hoffmann because you might
find that a nice evening young memory to
bite straight in use now therefore think
it up is put your pens down and engage
your mind when you see sine theta equals
1/2 sine theta is talking about the
white corner yes the Y quarter
so what you're really solving when you
see side beta into the heart is why even
the hot like because that's what soybean
is about I'm not worrying about
obviously not her focus anymore I'm
thinking about where often down I am or
visited circle because that's about
where I am up and down on the Cartesian
plane does that make sense to use all
I'm gonna do I'm going to take one from
the heart and I'm just going to draw it
on the UNICEF okay I pick up the pen
again remember this being in a circle
this top point here is what it's one
okay so therefore wife is a heart should
be half way up to get to there somewhere
like that
so get your ruler out and on top of your
unit circle just draw the line y equals
1/2
okay
now while searching for tis what this
means
where does wife or the heart intersect
with the incircle
okay and you can see it play today there
are two spots you see that choose from
the executive CR and here you agree
those two spots are my solutions okay so
all I have to do is try and think about
what angle rotating around the interval
will get me to the spot so here's a
button
yeah right
how about this is the jeans distraction
the white one is a half that's that
distance there
yes so if you're thinking now in that
right angle triangle is what I've drawn
here okay this is a half
so in the table our heart on one is
science side bibbity will stop us right
now that will exact so if you know and
if you're not sure your calculator can
confirm it for you in this little
triangle here
do you agree it's just like this
triangle you're done that triangle
except that everything is just half the
size this is our heart and what's that
radius again the unit circle for the
radius is 1 it's the same triangle
I just shrunk it on sale so therefore
being that our sundaland scale that
corner angle is still going to be 30
degrees ok so then my first solution I
just read it off like that
so the next thing I do is I say wait
there's a second solution on the other
side of the unit circle over there now
here's the brilliant time I remember
over here we had to remember arbitrarily
we have to say our a and s they're
positive cosine is positive so therefore
you get an acute angle and you get an
obtuse angle ok but over here on the
unit circle just going to work for you
look at this he is is the angle to get
to that point over there
the poisel is the free extension so now
all I have to do is find out what that
angle one looks symmetrical right good
it's a circle so this is 30 and what
this also 30 okay so therefore that
supplement a go to the 100 just a
different couple loops and that's why
this is one of these I'd like what my T
plus be done it's a hundred and eighty
minus the same angle cuz symmetrical
that's what the units
is so therefore on the basis of this I
say man attorney very early so my two
solutions are enough equal 30 degree or
150 so what I like about this what I
like about this is it turned down the
fact that we have redefined what they
should mention friction up they're not
about right angle triangles mealy and
out about where you are on the unit
circle
you must wrap your head around that
yours right yeah my son really hopefully
drawer and write to revision no be in
addition what does it really confirm to
you this thing which believe me is there
be some fun later on special when we
look at a topic called parametric not
going away you might as well learn to
understand what's going on TR and just
use it to help resolve people
yes interrupting a FTC business you have
to worry about all over a hundred of my
negative the unit circle just kind of
done the work force so that would
message it as if you can agree there's
much less working but just to think a
little bit harder that think you
developed understanding which is
understand really
what